Nos dicen: "Aquí tenemos las razones aproximadas
para ángulos de 25°, 35° y 45°". Lo que están
diciendo aquí es que si tuvieras que tomar la
longitud del cateto adyacente y dividirlo entre
la longitud de la hipotenusa, para un ángulo
de 25° la razón sería aproximadamente 0.91,
para un ángulo de 35° la razón sería de 0.82, y
luego aquí está la razón para un ángulo de 45°,
y por acá tenemos las diferentes razones. De
modo que vamos a usar la tabla para aproximar
la medida del ángulo D en el siguiente triángulo.
Pausa este video y trata de resolverlo. Muy bien,
trabajemos juntos en esto. ¿Qué información nos
dan sobre el ángulo D en este triángulo? Bueno,
aquí tenemos la longitud del cateto opuesto que
es 3.4, y también nos dan este lado. ¿Cuál es este
lado que tenemos aquí? ¿Es el cateto adyacente o es
la hipotenusa? Puede ser que tengas la tentación
de decir que, como está justo al lado del ángulo y
es una de las líneas o está en el rayo que ayuda a
formar el ángulo, tal vez sea el cateto adyacente,
pero recuerda que el cateto adyacente es el lado
adyacente que no es la hipotenusa, y este lado es
claramente la hipotenusa, es el lado más largo,
es el lado opuesto al ángulo de 90°, así
que este lado es la hipotenusa. Entonces
nos dan la longitud del cateto opuesto
y la longitud de la hipotenusa. Veamos:
¿cuál de estas razones involucra al cateto
opuesto y a la hipotenusa? Esta razón es del
cateto adyacente y la hipotenusa, la segunda
razón es del cateto opuesto y la hipotenusa,
así que esto es exactamente de lo que estamos
hablando, estamos hablando de la longitud del
cateto opuesto sobre la hipotenusa, la longitud
de la hipotenusa. En este caso, ¿cuánto será la
longitud del cateto opuesto sobre la longitud
de la hipotenusa?, ¿cuánto será 3.4 / 8?
Vamos a hacer esto aquí abajo. Este 8 cabe en
3.4, 8 no cabe en 3, 8 cabe en 34 cuatro veces,
4 x 8 es 32, ahora lo restamos, el resultado
es 2; puedo bajar un 0, 8 cabe en 20 dos veces,
y esto tiene tanta precisión como cualquiera
de estos números. Así que para este triángulo
en particular, y para este ángulo del triángulo
de la razón de la longitud del cateto opuesto y
la longitud de la hipotenusa, cateto opuesto
sobre hipotenusa, he obtenido 0.42. Parece
que tengo esto justo aquí, eso implica
que es un ángulo de 25° aproximadamente.